we're joined now by Congress with Devin
Nunez of California great to see you
congressman so great to be with you we
got an indication from Senator Lamar
Alexander of Tennessee last night late
that we're not going to get witnesses in
the Senate portion of this proceeding
and basically there's nothing left
there's gonna be a vote the president's
gonna be acquitted so why is it
continuing exactly do you know well they
have to actually get to the point of
where they actually vote to acquit which
I guess is gonna occur on Wednesday so
they had to vote on the rules for that
but I actually have some bad news for
you tonight Tucker on Friday night I
know he I know he don't want the bad
news but I'm used to the president's
going to be acquitted but the problem is
this isn't going to end like I I just
can't imagine that Adam Schiff after
three and a half years of this nonsense
and Jerry Nadler are not going to
continue this right they're going to go
back and they're gonna subpoena john
bolton we're gonna have the same exact
thing that you've been seeing for the
last three and a half years I just think
you should prepare we thought once
Moeller collapsed completely we thought
okay we're gonna get on to business and
then out of nowhere this Ukraine hoax
appeared and look this really is a hoax
this was Adam Schiff and his staff
concocting this all together with people
that all know each other all these
people know each other that concocted
this stupid Ukraine hoax that we've been
dealing with for the last week in the
Senate so anyway bad news for you
tonight I bet even after the acquittal
we're gonna be working on this so since
you're an elected official and you know
a lot about policy but also politics is
there any evidence that this works I
mean my read on it is the candidates who
win are the ones that speak to the
issues that people really care about
they don't care about this to monstera
Blee so why are Democrats continuing to
do this well I described it earlier this
week as the Democratic Party is like the
dog that caught the car and now they're
they've been promising all this crazy
stuff and now they're gonna get somebody
who's not even a Democrat Bernie Sanders
as their nominee a month ago I would
have said now you know Bernie's gonna
get second or third probably not gonna
win
I mean he's winning in every state
including California which is the big
prize which is essentially a month
yes and he's winning - no Iowa I mean
this could be if if Bernie wins on
Monday night
you have an entire takeover by the
extreme left of the historic Democratic
Party it's no longer inning that ceased
to exist it's going to be the Socialist
Party well so can I ask you another
political question so this is
essentially a replay of what happened
with Donald Trump in the Republican
Party the establishment hated him they
tried to rig the system to prevent him
from becoming the nominee and it didn't
work the Democrats are trying the same
thing they're talking about tampering
with delegates at the convention now
will that work well I think there's a
there's a big difference between Trump
and Bernie Sanders here okay
Trump Trump and I mean just in the
politics of this Bernie Sanders is a
socialist I mean the guy spent his
honeymoon in the Soviet Union yes right
Donald Trump had a you know he had his
own brand of politics that I think
caught everybody off guard but he does
believe in a few important things right
he but he wants to he's been very clear
he was against the Iraq war from the
very beginning he once he wants to bring
the troops home as much as he can he
also wanted to redo trade deals all all
things that people including myself were
very skeptical if he could actually
deliver on some of this but I think
despite all the craziness and for three
and a half years well really since the
end of 2015 Donald Trump and his
campaign being under investigation by
the feds the Clinton campaign the
Democrats in the house despite all of
that the guy is defying the odds I mean
I would have never thought that we could
have not only rewrote NAFTA but actually
passed it it was one of the most popular
trade agreements ever passed in that in
the House of Representatives and the
Senate
it's amazing what he's actually
accomplishing I remember despite
everything yeah and in the end that's I
think I think that's what matters
congressman thanks so much for coming on
I appreciate that Thank You Tucker
always a pressure